[relaxed surf music]
- Aloha, aloha, aloha,
my friends!
Hey, what's up?
- What's going on?
- Here you go.
I got you some boogie boards
as sort of a thank-you
for coming all this way
to do "House Party."
I really appreciate it.
Mahalo.
- Thanks.
Uh, I don't really boogie.
Uh, but thanks
for buying us these gifts.
- Oh, no, I--
I didn't buy them.
They call me
a cheap bastard.
I'm regifting them
because a magical tree elf
gave them to me, so...
- A magical tree elf?
- Mm-hmm.
- I think there's a mix-up.
You only rented us one room,
and it's three of us.
- I don't have
the mental capacity
to deal with your problems
and also kick it
with this
very beautiful,
magical tree elf
that I'm kicking it
with right now.
She is...
Bla-dow!
- Really?
Like, for real?
'Cause I would like--
I would love to see her,
if I could.
Like, you could take me
to the tree.
- And, Leonard,
I wish you could,
but I'm not sure if you can.
- Why?
- Because you need
to possess a childlike mind,
which luckily I do possess,
mostly because I read
at a middle school level.
Have you ever read
"James and the Giant Peach"?
- The only peach I like
is cobbler.
- Don't worry
about giant peaches.
Just worry about your set,
and enjoy your stay
at Turtle Bay!
Like "Jurassic Park,"
but I said "Turtle Bay"!
[theme music plays]